[Music]
586 on your monday morning hey a bigger
ear
wants to hear what's driving you crazy
the nevada department of transportation
has opened up public comment on how they
are doing maintaining the 5400 miles of
road they're in charge of around the
state with what traffic nerds call
14 billion vmt that's vehicle miles
traveled
so it is a 10 minute ndot online survey
that asks about
highway smoothness striping rest areas
work zones snow removal well it's a
statewide survey
and overall satisfaction now not
mentioned specifically in
in the ndot press release but they note
that they do want your thoughts on
interstates some of which just happen to
have
the hov lanes that some people just
might have an opinion on the survey is
going to be up until next wednesday the
18th
at www.nevadadot.com
survey that link and more info on our
website eightnewsnow.com you click
traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email's great but so are pictures
and video send it all to traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com